aquí hice algo diferente con el robot
tomé un kit para hacer algunas pruebas e
hice un par de cosas diferentes una de
ellas es que ver el kit que tome no
traía palitos de madera y me puse a ver
que encontraba y vi unas tablas de
circuitos y las cortes a veces hay que
usar lo que encontramos también mientras
buscaba con que reemplazar los palitos
de madera
me encontré estos clips de metal que usé
para colocar las baterías así ya no me
tengo que preocupar porque si despegue
el silicón y tener que volver a pegarlo
aquí sencillamente lo podemos poner y
quitar como pueden ver lo cual es bueno
porque nos facilita mucho cambiar las
baterías
también vean que no use el broche para
papel o clip ya que sin darme cuenta
estas pinzas de metal me ayudan a que la
araña no se bambolee si pongo las pilas
un poco hacia afuera de las pinzas así
como también puedo mover las pilas para
ajustarlas y obtener el equilibrio
correcto lo que es genial vamos a verla
en funcionamiento la programe para que
dé vueltas y ahí va
gira que gira hacia un lado y hacia el
otro como pueden ver el cambio en cómo
poner las baterías le da una muy buena
estabilidad y tengo que atraparla en el
momento justo
como pueden ver con estos sencillos
cambios pues tengo una araña que es
mucho más sencilla de actualizar ya que
no tengo que despegar y pegar las
baterías para poder cambiarlas ya que
las baterías son una parte integral de
la estructura también creo que usar las
tabletas del circuito fue una buena
improvisación cualquier cosa que
tengamos que sea de un grosor
consistente nos puede servir aquí pues
simplemente yo me encontré esto y
funciona también noten que hay algo más
que es diferente las tapas de las ruedas
no están tan pegadas al motor y lo hice
así porque aunque no se los mostré en el
vídeo pueden ver que hay un espacio
entre las ruedas y el motor y es porque
si se fijan en el eje del motor éste es
más angosto hacia el final por lo que no
quise poner la tapa hasta el fondo aquí
podemos ver otro motor en donde el
extremo de su eje tiene esta textura y
por eso decidí colocar hasta aquí la
rueda para que esta región con textura
proporciona la mayor fricción a ésta
además así no tenemos que preocuparnos
de que la tapa se vaya a aflojar mucho
fue bastante divertido hacer estas
modificaciones al proyecto